at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands start
shaking this episode is brought to you
by sure Sh you are a the company behind
some of my favorite microphones and
headphones in fact this podcast has been
recorded since day one effectively in
all of the live interviews with sure
microphones whether it is the sm58
switch looked like stage mics which
bryan callen introduced me to or the
table mounted sm7b s and most recently
I've been testing one of their
headphones sc8 for six rolls off the
tongue doesn't it these are now my
favourite in-ear headphones and I always
use them when I'm at coffee shops or
when I'm traveling sure earphones have
been famous for decades now with
professional musicians and their
wireless sound isolating earphones are
truly incredible the reason that I have
doubled down on these earphones
specifically is because when I use these
on my laptop as one example I can keep
the volume at say one out of ten and
hear things perfectly whereas when I use
normal earbuds I'm at easily 7 or 8 out
of 10 just to drown out external noise
and I become very very concerned with
hearing loss I've seen a lot of my
friends losing their hearing because
they're blasting their ears with normal
ear buds on their phones and laptops and
so on so I am using this as an
investment in my own hearing among other
things and they're very very comfortable
the SE 846 which I mentioned the sound
isolating earphones feature a
groundbreaking low-pass filter that
delivers extended high-end clarity and
unparalleled low-end performance so
check it out visit sure calm Shu re calm
forward / Tim use the code Tim at
checkout that's capital T
I am as a special offer for listeners of
this show you can receive $100 discount
on the SE 846 headphones this offer will
only be available until the end of
January 2018 let's take a look again
that's sure calm forward-slash Tim $400
off this episode is brought to you by
freshbooks
man oh man do a lot of listeners of this
podcast and readers of mine love fresh
books to the extent that I ended up
meeting with the CEO not very long ago
why are they so popular well they are
the number one cloud accounting software
designed exclusively for self-employed
professionals that's many of you and
used by more than 10 million people you
can send invoices track your time and
get paid very very quickly which suits
the needs of a lot of freelancers a lot
of entrepreneurs and beyond you can take
pictures of receipts you can link your
credit card and debit cards so all the
things you buy automatically appear in
your fresh books in the right category
so on and so forth makes taxes easy
makes invoices easy makes your life
easier and also in fact I recommend a
PDF they didn't ask me to read this part
by the way they put together PDF a while
back called breaking the time barrier
subtitle how to unlock your true earning
potential so you can search for breaking
the time barrier a lot of people ask me
how can I get a 4-hour workweek with the
service business and the story in that
ebook its PDF is the short answer it's
really really good so I think you should
also check that out so breaking the time
error check it out but also why not test
out fresh books claim your 30-day
unrestricted free trial at fresh
ebooks.com forward slash tim and enter
tim ferriss two hours in two S's in the
how did you hear about us section that
sounds like we're gonna get very little
tracking that's a lot of work but just
go to fresh books comm forward slash tim
and try it out because it is a very good
product and i think you will find it
simplifies your life enjoy
why hello there ladies and gentlemen
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
you may also be listening to this on the
usually shorter form tribe of mentors
podcast the guest this episode applies
to both equally Gretchen Rubin she is in
the book tribe of mentors and has lots
of tactical practical advice to offer
but we take it a little longer in format
this time around and we really do a deep
dive into experiments and creativity
happiness creative flow daily routines
etc Gretchen Rubin maybe you've heard of
her Twitter Facebook at Gretchen Rubin
are you bi n Gretchen Rubin comm who is
Gretchen she's the author of several
books including the New York Times
bestsellers better than before the
Happiness Project happier at home and
most recently the four tendencies her
books have sold nearly three million
copies worldwide that's a lot of copies
in more than 30 languages on her popular
podcast happier with Gretchen Rubin she
discusses good habits and happiness with
her sister Elizabeth craft they've been
called the clicking clack of podcasters
her podcast was named one of iTunes best
podcasts of 2015 and the Academy of
podcasters best podcast of 2016 Fast
Company named Gretchen to its list of
most creative people in business and
she's a member of Oprah's super soul 100
so without further ado please enjoy my
wide-ranging conversation with Gretchen
Rubin
Gretchen welcome to the show I'm so
happy to be talking to you I have been
looking forward to this for some time
many many many many of my listeners and
fans have been requesting that you come
on the show and here we are so thank you
for making the time oh that's great to
hear and I'm so glad to get the chance
to sit down and talk to you so I thought
we would begin actually with a a
question that's been on my mind related
to a tweet of yours which is not
scandalous I'm just hoping to hear you
elaborate a bit on where it came from
which is a notebook with I wish I could
not wish agree or disagree and where
does that come from what is the origin
of that well I love Cohen's you know
which are these statements that then
Buddhist monks will meditate on in order
to free themselves from the bounds of
kind of rational thought so this is what
is the sound of one hand clapping and
things like that and so I'm always
looking for things like that are kind of
paradoxical statements and that get you
thinking and that was one I wish I could
not wish was one that really was an idea
that occurred to me that I was like yeah
I do sometimes I wish that I could not
wish and it's an interest it's like one
of these things that the more you think
about it your thoughts kind of twist and
turn and that's what I like about
Cohen's
know what prompted the desire to lose
the ability to wish is it the
expectations - reality equals happiness
type of equation and not having that
forward seeking expectation or desire or
was it something else like what was what
were the circumstances that surrounded
you not or considering the the desire to
lose your ability to wish well actually
you know I'm sort of deeply within the
Romantic tradition so I'm a big believer
in desire and attachment as as part of
life so I don't I'm not a person who
really wants to disengage from from
desire but certainly I have times where
my wishing I wish I couldn't wish I wish
I wasn't wishing but for me it was
really more of
thought exercise than something that I
bet passionately rang true for me
personally I feel like I wish that I
wish sometimes I wish that I had more
wishes that I felt more strongly towards
things because I think there's a lot of
power and beauty that comes from that
yeah
where did where did the we're gonna
bounce around a lot since I'm strictly
non chronological how did the law end up
entering your life I mean it seems like
you had some family with legal
backgrounds but it was there a point
where you decided you want to proceed to
pursue that as a profession yeah you're
right my father's a lawyer very happy
lawyer so I had a model in my life of a
someone who was very happy as a lawyer
but really I just drifted into law you
know I was good at research and writing
I was good at taking tests and you know
I thought about law school well um you
know well just take the ALS 80 and see
how I do I'll just apply to law school
and see where I get in and I can always
change my mind later and it's a great
preparation for a lot of different
things and you know I'll keep my options
open and I never really sat down and
thought you know I would really like to
be a lawyer and the fact is law school
is really great if you're a person who
really wants to be a lawyer
um and the people I know who are happy
lawyers and they wanted to be lawyers
but I went to law school just because I
sort of didn't know what else to do with
myself
and I had a great experience in law
school I got I'm glad that I went but I
certainly just drifted into it
because of a lack of any other aim and
it just it just seemed like something
safe too like a safe thing to do that
would maybe help help me get more
clarity they you you were very
successful in law as far as I can tell
I'm no legal professional but I mean you
were the editor in chief of the Yale Law
Journal you want some very prestigious
prizes how are you why were you as good
at navigating that system as you were if
you were not passionate
about it well it's interesting because
yeah the word say is saying that I
drifted into law school kind of sounds
like it's the lazy kind of easygoing way
and one of the things I found about when
people drift is it doesn't mean that
it's easy or that you're not working
hard so I worked really hard and like
you said yeah I was editor in chief of
the Law Journal I went on to clerk for
Justice Sandra Day O'Connor I worked
really really hard at it um but at a
certain point I you know I sort of did
the obvious next thing you know like oh
oh I'm graduating from law school I'll
apply for a clerkship oh I got one clerk
shop I'll apply to the Supreme Court and
then I got to a point where it's like
well now what are you gonna do and I
thought I don't really know I don't I
mean hey I could there's all these law
jobs that I could try for but none of
them really appealed to me and that's
when I started thinking about the fact
that maybe I needed to think about going
in a different direction what what
directions did you can you place us in
terms of your life as to where you were
what you were doing it was there a
particular evening or a conversation or
dinner or event that catalyzed you
thinking you know I don't want to
continue on this path I want to consider
other options was there a particular
straw that broke the camel's back or a
moment yeah um well I'm really lucky
because I'm and I think this is true for
a lot of writers but actually for many
people in many different kinds of
professions something started pulling me
very very hard and and writing began to
pull me and what happened to me was I
had the idea this is probably the most
critical thing that happened I had the
idea that eventually did turn into the
first book that I ever published so I
was taking a walk onto my lunch hour and
I was looking up at the Capitol dome you
know all white against the blue sky and
I thought well and just sort of as a
kind of a you know a mental just kind of
fun game to play with myself I said what
am i interested in that everybody in the
world is interested and I thought well
power money fame sex and all of a sudden
it's like power money fame sex and to me
this like locked into my mind as this
kind of unified idea and I became
obsessed
with trying to research and understand
and analyze and write about power money
fame sex and this is something that
happens to me often I will often become
obsessed with subjects and do tons of
research so this is not that was not
something unusual that that happened has
happened to me my whole life it's like
my favorite thing about myself actually
um but this was like unstoppable I was
spending all my free time working on
this and at some point I was like this
is the kind of thing that a person would
do if they were writing a book I'm just
doing this in my free time but this is
the kind of thing somebody would do to
write a book about it and and and and
slowly I began to think well maybe I
should write a book about it
and I literally went to the bookstore
and got a book called something like how
to write and sell your non-fiction book
proposal I got the book and just follow
the directions and and part of my
thinking was you know I've come to a
point where I'd rather fail as a writer
than succeed as a lawyer and I need to
try I need to try and fail or try and
succeed but I need to like to do it and
but I think I was lucky because I knew
what I wanted not only did I want to be
a writer I wanted to write this specific
book and so there was immense clarity
about my purpose sometimes I think when
people and I bet you've seen this too
where people know they don't know they
don't want what they have but they don't
know what they want and so they're kind
of in what color is my parachute kind of
thing and that's hard and for me it was
almost like I can't help but write this
book I feel compulsion to write this
book so why don't I see if like this is
my next thing and then and then that's
and then that was how I made the switch
was from that book on writing it strikes
me at least for me can be very difficult
even if you have a deep desire to write
about a given subject the actual process
of writing is easier for some certainly
quite hard for many I would say that I'm
a very slow plodding writer and where
I'm going with that I guess is when did
you actually cut bait and quit your job
was it it were had you already sold the
book
were you had you already sold it in your
part way through writing it or did you
just kind of throw caution to the wind
and quit before the proposal had been
sold at what point did you actually stop
the salary so to speak from them from
the job from the from the legal
profession well it actually it was it
was like the catalyst was other changes
in my life so I had I married my husband
who I met in law school that was one of
the benefits of going to law school I'm
and he was working as a lawyer too and
we were living in Washington DC and we
were getting ready to move back to New
York and he took it he took a class in
financial accounting and he didn't apply
for a la job he applied for a job in
finance and I didn't apply for a la job
I was just like now I'm in at work
full-time I'm trying to get an agent
trying to write this proposal and so for
us it was like the move from DC was like
okay we're leaving that behind it I
remember we got to New York and at one
point we got a letter from the Bar
Association of New York because we were
both members of the New York Bar saying
you owe us bar fees Victor wait quite
it's quite heavy and I said Jamie you
know should we play should we pay our
bar fees and just like keep it up and
he's like are you kidding no I'm like
yeah work we're cutting that out you
know and so that was like so it was
really made easy for me because this
physical move correspondent with like
everything's different now we're
switching total professions my my whole
routine is different my aim is different
my aim now really at that point was to
get an agent which is really harder
probably than getting a book contract
and I had no idea what I was doing but
so that's that's when it was it was like
it was like I'm gonna work up until this
time but when I'm in New York I'm not
gonna look for a lot job in New York I'm
not gonna look for any other job this
now is my full-time profession is to try
to get published and when you published
that first book looking back at it now
what were some of the key lessons
learned through the process of searching
for the agent to publishing that first
book and I suppose going on the road and
trying to promote that first book were
there any particular life lessons or
lessons learned look
back that then informed later decisions
for you well you know it's funny I you
know I I I talked to several people
before I ended up with my agent who is
like you know that one of the most
important people in my life now Christie
Fletcher who's like this huge influence
on my career and it's this complete love
connection but I talked to other agents
before I met her and one agent said
something at the time I thought was
preposterous but in hindsight I began I
I have learned that what she meant and
why she was right she said you have too
many ideas on each page and I was like
there's no such thing as too many ideas
on a page like what we want here is lots
and lots of ideas and I thought she was
just like so wrong but then I realize
like one problem with my writing and
this is something that I fight all the
time is density it's like I want to just
cut cut cut and only have dense but you
can't read a book like that you have to
have humor you have to have connective
tissue you have to have pacing you have
to have high you know you have to have
you it has to have breath in it and and
so that's one thing that I I wish that I
could go back to her and say I
I understand now the wisdom of what you
said and and I think about it often and
even now in my writing and it's you know
many many years later as to the
publishing process I mean I would just
say to anybody who's trying to get
published traditionally you know
obviously now a lot of people can self
publish which is a whole other route um
getting an agent is hard that is really
really hard don't think that that's just
like a quick easy step and that writing
the book is the hardest part I think you
know getting an agent and and that that
I think probably for many people is the
most challenging stage of traditional
publishing I don't know what do you
think what do you think is the most huh
that's a good question I mean I was
turned down by three or four agents
before signing with my agent Steve
Hanselman and he's still my agent and
announced then I was subsequently turned
down by 27
in Lingle right she had like 32 I think
something yeah and you know I think that
there are you know just because a book
is rejected doesn't mean it's a good
book certainly I mean I think there are
bad ideas that get rejected and there's
also an argument to be made that perhaps
for those publishers this book was not a
good fit maybe maybe not but ultimately
for me I think the I given my past
experiences and professional experience
entrepreneurial experience before the
nonfiction book selling process and I
think one thing that's important for
people to understand if they're
listening to this and don't have any
background in publishing generally
speaking in nonfiction you're almost you
can almost treat it like raising money
for a venture-backed startup you go out
with this idea and a business plan ie
a book proposal you sell it and then you
write it if you write a nonfiction book
and try to go out and sell it it is
incredibly difficult it is more
difficult in most respects than going
out with a proposal first conversely in
fiction it's the other way around right
if you try to sell an idea for a fiction
book especially if you're untested it's
not gonna happen unless you have a
completed manuscript so so the the sales
process for me was easier than the
writing process because I had more
experience I had a lot of experience
with long sales cycles because the job
immediately well I should say prior to
starting my company before that in which
case I was dealing with large retailers
and so on which had extended sales
cycles I had been selling massive or I
should say mass data storage systems to
organizations like the FBI American
Airlines and so on which also meant
multiple month sales cycles so I was
comfortable in the realm of working with
a proposal to sell a publisher I was
less familiar with the process of
actually writing a book so the writing
was the hardest
process for me and I was also accustomed
to rejection which i think is not
something many people have inoculated
themselves against whereas if you are in
an external sales position you're
getting rejected all the time so I
didn't view that as a huge blow to my
morale it was just part of racking up
enough knows that I would statistically
get to a yes effectively but but I'm
curious to know for you after this first
book and we're not gonna spend the whole
time focusing on on the book stuff
although I'm fascinated by it how did
you decide on your next book because you
mentioned and I have this challenge as
well I mean I do these deep dives on
many different subjects you could go a
million different directions how how did
you narrow all the options down or if
that's even how it came about to do your
next book how did you how do you end up
deciding well you know in retrospect I
didn't realize this at the time it took
me a while like I was several books in
before I realized kind of my own theme
but my theme is human nature that's what
every book that I've written everything
that I'm interested in some way is an
examination of human nature through from
a different perspective and so power
money fame sex which was actually
excellent background for writing about
happiness because you know there's sort
of the opposite of happiness and then so
my next book was 40 ways to look at
Winston Churchill and I think I was I
know that I was drawn to Winston
Churchill because he's such a gigantic
character everything in him is so huge
he's so studied he was part of
everything in the world for decades I
mean he and he was you know whether or
not you and you agree with his policies
or his statements he was you know it
played an extraordinarily important role
and then he was also a brilliant writer
he's extraordinarily gifted writer he
painted I mean he was just sort of a
million things um and and so for me I
was very drawn to how do you tell the
story and it like in a succinct
interesting accessible way you know
people have written you know eight
volumes of his life could I do it in you
know 250 pages in a way that would be
honest and be helpful be interesting to
people and so you know each of my book
is sort of led in the next one so I
wrote forty ways to look at Winston
Churchill then I wrote 40 ways to look
at JFK
I wanted to try this with another
character I wrote this really weird
little book called profane waste which
was about like why owners just destroy
their own possessions which is a subject
again that had obsessed me since law
school and why didn't I get it why did
that obsess you since law school well
you know um it's hard to explain why
it's so obsesses me but you know if you
think about like the standard idea and
certainly in law school we talked a lot
about this about like the idea of what
it means to possess what makes sense is
that people who possess things try
owners try to try to preserve things or
control things why would they why would
someone want to burn their house to the
ground and is it legal to burn your own
house to the ground or like there was a
Japanese businessman like mogul who
announced that he was going to bury his
impressionist masterpieces with him and
there was huge public outcry why do we
think that it's worse for him to bury it
with him in his grave than to like keep
it in a basement in a bank why you know
why do people if you've seen the movie
Harold and Maude there's that moment
when Maude throws the ring into the lake
and says now I know now I'll never know
where it is and to me like this
incredibly powerful and kind of taboo
thing to do so I was just trying to
understand it so again it was just like
some weird preoccupation that I had and
it turns out this is like this whole
rich crazy examples of people doing this
and why they do it and well how how you
would explain it and then I got into the
whole like happiness and habits and sort
of what I'm known for now but it's all
because it's all related to human nature
and so for me they feel very connected
and one led very logically to the next I
think from the outside it doesn't always
look like that but that's definitely how
it feels to me like I'm always I always
am thinking about I always have things
that I'm I'm dying to get to as soon as
I can when when you do a deep dive on
something whether it's for a book or
otherwise how do you take notes
what is your note-taking system oh I
love taking out so it's and it I'm so
glad you asked about it because it's a
huge part of what I do and so I'll read
book and I really
I always get my ideas I do everything
through reading like I'm a very unwell
rounded person and and I don't really do
interviews with people or anything like
that like in terms of research I do it
all through reading um and I read the
weirdest craziest stuff and so I will
whenever I read a book I will take
extensive notes so anything that strikes
my fancy I will take a note of it so I
have a document that's just called and
quotes 2006 plus and that's just
anything that I think is particularly
beautiful then I have subject notes that
I take like on habits or color or
happiness or you know if I have big
subjects and then everything gets dumped
into there is separate Word documents or
what what are those are separate Word
documents by topic and then there's no
internal structure in these notes I own
I just will put like I would my might
tag something so if let's say it was
about let's say I was going to take a
note about some habits research I might
tag it accountability tracking health so
that so then what happens so I have
these giant documents of notes and then
it's and then it eventually turns into a
book because at a certain point I have
enough notes on a subject that I have
started to form my own ideas and started
to have my own viewpoint my own you know
my own ideas about who I agree with who
I think it's you know what what people
are missing what needs to be added or
explained that isn't already added isn't
already you know kind of out there and
then I will start moving things from the
notes into my own structure and so I
will use those tagging words to find
things like if I'm writing a chapter
about accountability I'll go through and
pull put everything I would dump it into
the accountability section and from
there then I would begin to turn it into
my own original writing and the
advantage of this is I never have a
blank page because I'm always working
from huge amounts of notes but taking
notes is a big part of my workday it's
it sounds like oh it's very perfunctory
but it actually it's it's there's a lot
of thinking that goes into it and then
just like the the sheer copying things
out then that also helps me remember
things because I I need to remember a
lot and so I find that physically
copying things helps me retain
information so I'll sometimes copy
things just so that I I can refer back
to it easily but then it also makes it
easier for me to remember
you know like what that what did that
study say or what was what was the
definition of extensive anyway or
whatever that helps me and when you're
copying things and pasting them let's
just say into your own format or
structure structure thank you eat from a
software perspective are you still using
word for that and it's just a separate
document or is there is are you using a
different approach well so with one of
my books I use Scrivener and I really
really like Scribner but I'm super untuk
II and every once in a while Scribner
would be like now it's time to update
and that made me super scared because I
felt like my my document was sort of B I
couldn't get to it and it was so
unnerving to me that I haven't used
Scribner sense even though I had a great
experience with it because I was just
like I really didn't like that because I
think if I were very technically savvy
then I would just do it and I wouldn't
worry about it but for me it was always
very anxiety-producing like am I gonna
do it right is something gonna happen
what if this whole thing goes away and I
have to do some week-long customer
service nightmare thing to retain you
know because this document is everything
to me you know it's so precious and so
now I just keep it in Word I'm like it's
like it was a little bit better but you
know it's just not worth the anxiety and
so now I do every I just create a Word
document
yeah so I have more anxiety associated
with word in and of itself so I actually
I I've actually used Scrivener for last
for books in terms of structuring and I
just automatically have developed the
schedule end auto backups that then drop
a zip file for the entire Scrivener file
into Dropbox so that I I have multiple
copies of the entire project backed up
into zip files but I'm always curious
about the software of course that's a
tool and there are perhaps more higher
level conceptual frameworks that are
more important when you are reading
these books are you reading hard copy or
you reading say Kindle and then
exporting highlights so that you can
copy and paste things digitally no
almost always I'm reading a hard car
a lot of the things that I read are old
and they don't exist in digital form
because they're like old random books
that nobody cares enough to digitize or
to have you know available commercially
but but I also I again I I find and this
is what the research shows is true for
many people it's certainly true for me
that I retain things more when I read
them in physical form and then I also I
feel like if I could just cut and paste
something I would do I would be tempted
to do that but I do think that the
actual physical copying even though I
know people say handwriting is even
better but my handwriting so bad I would
never be able to read it again for me
typing does again it helps me retain
information because so much of what I do
is like taking a giant subject and then
trying to crunch it down and so I have
to have a lot in my mind at one time so
for me just you know having a lot of
stuff in my working memory is very
helpful I had asked you for tribal
mentors the book that you were kind
enough to contribute to about books that
had had a significant impact on you or
that it affected your thinking or been
gifted by you often and the book you
brought up was a pattern language hmm
could you please explain because you've
read so many books why a pattern
language hmm so a pattern language is a
book by Christopher Alexander who's kind
of this whacky architect in California
and I love many books that he's written
but pattern language is interesting
because it's it's nonlinear so carrying
on in our land linear theme what he
looks at is why what makes the part
that's most interesting to me is like
what makes spaces most interesting and
comfortable for people and he's not
saying things like oh you know your
dining room chandelier it should be 30
inches off your dining room table or you
know you should have a curved doorway
not a square doorway things like that
it's much more poetic and it's and what
he does is he's he's looking and he and
his team looked all across cultures all
across the world in time to see what
were the patterns what's the pattern
language of what draws people into
feeling good in a space so for example
it's things like
half-wild garden terrace overlooking
life child cave secret place like he
says everybody's home should have a
secret place that only the people who
live there and the people they tell know
about and my I'm like when we moved I'm
like we are definitely having a secret
place in our apartment and we do we have
MIT we have a couple services or like
sleeping to the east it's like people
like to sleep through these like one
thing is here's one that really showed
me why I like certain kind of like
restaurants better ceilings at different
heights look around when you're in a
place that feels comfortable you'll
notice the ceilings are at different
heights and then if you're in a place
where the ceiling is all at the same
height it doesn't feel as good or like
cascade of roofs if you look at roofs
from Japanese temples to English manor
houses all across the you know Norwegian
farmhouses they have a cascade of roofs
and that's very pleasing and so if just
this I'm not very visual at all I can
only get I can only see things through
words and so I felt like reading this
book all of a sudden I was able to key
into my visual environment in a whole
new way and understand like why certain
spaces felt so inviting and comfortable
and then other spaces just turned me off
like over like light on two sides if
you're in a room that that has only
light on one side it's not comfortable
you're far more comfortable in a room
that has light on two sides pay
attention well you may living in New
York this is a huge thing where is your
light coming from how much light do you
have huge difference between having
light on one side and light on two sides
and so anyway so it's it's a very it's
organized its nonlinear it's just like
organizing like bits and pieces so you
could just pick it up and flip through
it it has illustrations and so you see
the common patterns in you know in like
a multitude of different architectures
their architectural styles and so it's
just it's very thought-provoking it
makes you see the world in a whole new
way which is my favorite thing so that's
why I love a pattern language I have to
pick it up I thought I knew that book
and I do not I I actually I think that I
was confusing it with a book called the
loom of language which is completely
different related to language
acquisition and absurdly absurdly dense
hey hostage a lot of pictures perfect
now given given all of that I a know or
at least based on my understanding you
do a lot of your work in a home office
what are the what are some of the key
ingredients that make your home office
your home office well the one thing
that's missing that I desperately want
but my office is too small is a
treadmill desk
I would love a treadmill desk I gave my
sister a treadmill desk she has a
treadmill desk but my office is too
small
um one thing that I love that I have is
three monitors and I I had for a long
time thought and I think a lot of people
think well that's just going to be
overwhelming it's gonna be too much
information coming at me it's gonna be
distracting like if I need to focus I
can't have three monitors but then I
read a study that said that knowledge
workers of which we are like their
productivity went up substantially when
they went from one to two monitors so I
got a second monitor as an experiment
and like the next day I bought a third
monitor and I think I would have a
fourth monitor if my desk were big
enough but my office is very small but
it's just if you just can go so much
faster like if I'm copying something
from the internet into a document it
takes one second I'm like looking up the
definition of a word I don't have to
close out of my document if my team if I
need to look up something in an email
like and and like read an email and look
up a map or something you can just do it
so seamlessly so that's something I love
I have a headset love a headset do you
have a particular headset or monitors
that that you like my monitors are just
like Dell basic they're all different
sizes to it so it's not very it's not
very sleek looking and it's a
Plantronics headset all very basic one
thing I got that I didn't even know I
was a pain point that I didn't even
realize I experienced until there was a
solution for it was I got a you know
like right now I'm speaking to you on a
headset that is plugged into my my hard
drive and for summary like the the the
headset wire was just like always under
my my role the rolling wheels of my
chair and I couldn't figure out where to
put my headset so that didn't get my way
and then I found home at The Container
Store
like a hook that you just put on the
side of a desk and then you hook your
headset to it I was like this is exactly
what I need so I have that I have a book
wait this is a very specific thing but
for people who take a lot of notes it's
just a strip of leather that has weights
on both ends so that if you have a like
a book that's not staying open enough
that you can read to copy it you can put
a book weight on it and it will hold it
open I got that as a present and I was
like what am I going to do with this and
now I'm like literally I use it every
single day it's so it's a flexible strip
of leather with weight on either end
yeah so if you need to trip a burglar
getting away on horseback you could but
you know I don't get I don't have that
much in terms of technology support it's
just like the basics and my laptop of
course which is like my puppy
practically I'm so you know emotionally
attached to my laptop
how do you know in a home office
environment one of the benefits is that
you can work when you want to work one
of the potential downsides is that you
can work at all times
how what are the rules or systems or
parameters policies whatever factors
that you've set in place so that you are
not in there at all hours or working
during family time or fill in the blank
how do you how do you contain that and
structure your days when you're when
you're when you're doing well that makes
sense yeah one thing I do is I will say
to myself like and it's a different time
every day but I will say like now is
quitting time and I was sort of in my
mind I think okay it's quitting time
and so like sure I might check my email
or I might like read a book that is
research not for fun but just like a
research book after that time but I'm
basically not I'm not working and then
and I also at that time will sort of
clean up my office and that also is kind
of a signal like okay this is I'm done
for the day I'm sort of setting up for
tomorrow
and so this is kind of it's coming to an
end you I'm not clean up your office
yeah like you know I'll carry my coffee
mugs to the kitchen and I'll file
anything that you know and throw away
anything that needs to be thrown away or
like if I got a book off the shelf put
the book back put the caps on the pens
you know that sort of thing just to kind
that makes it a lot nicer to come in in
the next morning and also it just it's
kind of a visual signal like now I'm
winding down for the day I'm kind of
lucky because I live in an apartment but
my office used to be a water tower and
the people before who lived in our
apartment before us turned it into a
storage room but a nice storage room
with like windows and an air-conditioner
and heat and then when we moved I was
like I could make that my office so I'm
sort of lucky because I have to go up a
little flight of stairs let's go to my
office and so it's not like I think of
your office is like next to your kitchen
it's just right there all the time works
for me I like I actually have to open up
a door go out and on my service stairs
and go upstairs and so I think that also
makes it a little bit easier because
it's just you know one of the things
about whenever we're trying to get
ourselves to not do something making it
inconvenient the slightest bit of
inconvenience makes it harder to get to
something which is you know which we can
use to try to make our habits better so
I think for me that's that's the thing
like once I'm down in my once I'm like
okay it's quitting time I'm going down
my little staircase that kind of creates
a barrier which is very helpful so you
mentioned you mentioned habits and where
it's come up a few times so since that
door is open let's let's step into it
based on what I've read one of the
reliable small changes that people can
make or claim that they've made that
makes them predictably happier is making
their bed we're making their beds are
there other small changes that you would
also recommend for people who are hoping
to increase their self-reported
well-being slash happiness well one
thing that seems to work for a lot of
people is the one minute rule this is
the rule that if there's anything you
can do in less than a minute you do it
without delay so if you can print out a
document and delete the email due and
file it do that if
you can scan a letter and throw it away
do that if you can hang up your coat
instead of jumping it on a chair do that
if you can put a book back on the shelf
instead of just leaving it on the
counter do that and what this does for a
lot of people is just get rid of that
kind of scum of stuff on the surface of
life you know because sometimes it's not
that there's any one thing that's so you
know insurmountable to do but you just
feel like oh my gosh it just everywhere
I look I see everything's just kind of
out of order and I have to sift through
everything to find what I'm looking for
and so for a lot of people they say just
doing this just makes them feel like
well I've got the little things out of
the way and so now I'm I'm more ready to
tackle the big things and getting enough
sleep of course get enough sleep that is
like a huge one if you have the Hat and
here are some if you're having trouble
getting enough sleep shed an alarm most
adults need 7 hours of sleep most adults
know what time they're gonna get up in
the morning do the math give yourself an
alarm give yourself a bedtime so it's
not like oh I go to bed when I'm tired
it's like my bedtime is 10:30 and then
and you might even need a snooze alarm
just like you're how if you have one in
the morning you might have one at night
and it's like oh my alarm went off now I
have 15 minutes to get myself organized
and get to bed and then the alarm will
go off again and it's my bedtime
another thing another habit that can
help with this is get ready before your
bedtime I realized that I was staying up
late because I was too tired to get
ready for bed like I was too tired to
like watch my face and take all my
contacts and change my clothes it's
clearly very stupid approach so now I
get ready much earlier and so once when
I'm actually sleepy it's easy to turn
out the light because I'm already pretty
see do you you do you in other words you
do your pre bed ritual well before you
need to go to bed yes yeah yeah so I'm
right I'm ready but I'm a sleep zealot
I'm asleep dog but if you're looking for
like what's a habit that will make you
more energetic more immune to illness
higher focus and function better temper
and just feel better getting more sleep
if you don't get enough sleep already is
something that will show you will surely
benefit you and one of the
funny there's all this funny research
that they've done because we really
adjusted not getting enough sleep and so
people think that they're fine
they're like oh I've trained myself to
get by on four hours of sleep like
that's no problem for me but when
scientists study these people they're
quite impaired like we lose track of how
good we feel when we have enough sleep
and so you might think that you're fine
but actually if you had more sleep you
might feel a lot lot better have a lot
more energy have a lot more focus do you
have any particular winddown
routines or rituals at night well one I
have a I have a my daughter before she
goes to bed often we will have like
we'll just sit together and just kind of
like it's like time it's meant to be
time for her but it's actually time for
me to to kind of unwind and because
she's old enough that we go to bed at
more or less the same time because I am
asleep dolly and so that's one thing but
what do you guys what do you guys do
when you sit down she just pretty much
talks to me about her day you know or
like we'll talk about she's actually
very interested in being a writer too
and so sometimes we'll talk about write
early things I mean it's funny she was
reading this book and we had a long
discussion about pacing and a novel like
this book was very like you know the
pace of it was like very fast did we
like that like a book that covered ten
years versus a book that covers a summer
and so we'll talk about stuff like that
um which of course sprint for me is
tremendously fun but mostly we she just
tells me about like what happened in her
day and you know she's in seventh grade
so there's a lot of drama to catch me up
on but it's just a really nice way to
sit down and really connect at the end
of the day and it's very it's very
relaxing you know it's very very
peaceful um but I maybe because I am
such a sleep zealot and really do guard
it I don't I I
I feel like I wind down pretty quickly
and in the morning do you have any like
if you look at the first say 60 to 90
minutes of your day what does that look
like is it is it fairly standard from
day to day the first hour is because I
get up at 6 a.m. every day I walk my dog
I get coffee and then I sit down and do
what all the experts tell you
to do which as I spend the first hour of
my day checking my email in social media
which everybody says if you're a morning
person you should do your most intense
intellectual work then because that's
when you're at your best I definitely am
a morning person
but I realize like I can't focus on
anything until I check my inbox and see
what's going on check social media see
what's going on there
I just came just too distracted by that
until I get it done so I do that and
then it's time for my daughter to go to
school so often I'll walk her to school
she doesn't need me to walk her to
school but I do it just because it's fun
it's like a nice way to get out and then
I'll usually I'll often exercise so I
will either go for a walk in Central
Park or I'll go to the gym or I do
high-intensity strength training or a
yoga class and then and then so then
that's kind of the beginning of my day
and then I go into whatever am i
preparing for a podcast am i working on
a book am i talking to a reporter and I
writing an email and my planning you
know then then the rest of the day is
much more unpredictable or changes day
to day unfortunately I wish I had the
life of a Benedictine monk because I
would love to have every day be exactly
the same but it's not well you could
write I mean you give you ostensibly no
no because it's like journalists you
know they're like well I mean I'm in the
UK so I can't talk to you at 5:00
because for me that's the middle of the
night or I have to record a podcast that
has to happen at a certain time you know
and so I mean I would have to work so
hard to have that kind of it's I just
don't think it's worth it I mean I might
kind of enjoy it but I'm it's not worth
fighting for I in my mind for other
people it might they might they might
want to really make that a priority
well I guess I've just realized for
myself that there are certain categories
of activities media certainly being one
that make my schedule or make me create
a schedule that is more reactive then it
could be otherwise so at least one of my
fantasies we're talking now for people
who might be listening to this later
we're talking in December 2017 and one
of the recurring thoughts that I've had
is a three to six month sabbatical for
both media and social media okay so
media meaning interviews in social media
just to see what happens when I remove
those two categories of inputs that tend
to jostle and move things around as much
as they do I don't know what the outcome
would be I don't know if it will happen
although I I would certainly planning on
seeing Star Wars tonight or tomorrow so
if we're channeling inner Yoda I commit
or not commit but for for yourself I
mean you've written so much about
happiness if you were to look back over
the last could be five years it doesn't
have to be I'm just arbitrarily pulling
a number out what are what are some of
the changes that you've made that have
had the greatest impact on your either
levels of happiness or and these may be
the same thing increased happiness or
decreased anxiety and other negative
emotions one thing that I did was like
four years agos like I gave up sugar
quit sugar and and basically carbs so I
don't eat sugar pasta flour starchy
vegetables I don't really eat much I eat
almost no fruit so like the most curvy
things I eat are that green vegetables
and nuts so I do eat a lot of nuts which
help like a fair amount of carbs so and
this for me was the greatest thing I had
always had a really terrible sweet tooth
and and I hated the feeling of like can
I have this or it's just a bi eater it's
for free or it's my birthday or you know
that whole thing and I just like I just
and I write about this and better than
before that I realize I'm an abstainer
it's easier for me to have none then I
have a little bit and I just gave it up
I read this book why we get fat by Gary
Taubes
and I'm like overnight I'm like I'm
completely convinced I'm changing
everything about the way that I eat and
for me it was just the most freeing
energizing positive change and I also
used to get super hungry like shaking
sweating hungry because I was eating
like a very low fat diet and
not even that much protein and and so
and now I don't have that super
inconvenient so for me that was a huge
thing I'm not saying that would work for
everybody but that was for me
and and it was a very dramatic change my
husband actually gave me a Christmas
ornament in the shape of a strip of
bacon to like like memorialize this was
the year of the beginning of bacon
because boy and so that was a big thing
for me and in the last five years it
could be longer if well one thing that I
did that added tremendously to my
happiness um so I am like this crazy
raving fan of children's literature and
young adult literature so I read it as a
child and I read it now as an adult and
and I realized when I was writing The
Happiness Project that this was
something that I loved but I didn't
really make much time for it in my life
it kind of didn't fit with my idea of
myself that I was very sophisticated I
was a very kind of advanced reader who
read very you know kind of like very
adult things and but I realized you know
I don't really have that many true like
passions and interests and so I don't I
don't have enough that I can just ignore
one of the big ones and I started a
group for adults who read and loved
children's literature and young adult
literature and when I started it I truly
believed that there were no other adults
in New York City who would want to join
this group and and now there are three
of these groups I just actually had my
annual Christmas party when I get all
three groups together one one day a year
they all three meet and I'm a member of
all three but there were so many that
there had to be three separate groups
and it's been amazing because I met all
I've met a bunch of like book of people
who I love so I have more relationships
I have and these are people who share
something that I love I have a way to
talk about and learn about something
that I truly love and the fact is it's
it's like some people like mysteries
some people like sci-fi it's like some
people like children's literature and
young adult literature it's just a
different taste that some people have
and some people don't
as adults we there's nothing to do with
children in these groups and but that
was something where I'm like wow when I
look back on changes that I made that
gave me like huge
in happiness both kind of intellectually
and also through relationships because
relationships are probably the key to
happiness that was a big one that was a
big one kind of acknowledging that and
then like really bringing it into mice
like really shining a light on it in my
life letting it really kind of take its
place as a major occupation in my life
what is the rhythm of the groups look
like in terms of meetings and so on and
do you do you communicate via Facebook
groups email could you just paint a
picture of logistically how it actually
works and they all we all communicate
through email there so one of the
group's they're all a little bit
different one of the groups well they
all meet every six weeks and they all
take we all take turns meeting at
certain people's apartments like people
will take turns
some people have apartments that are too
small or too far away and so it's not
convenient so those people just don't
enter the rotation which is fine that's
just like whatever some people host some
people don't
one person never hosts so she always
brings dessert that's like her
contribution she brings dessert every
time so fine um one of the groups we
rotate among classic modern and
contemporary so we might read Peter Pan
and then Harriet the Spy and then they
hate you give you know we would do that
the other ones just pick books we just
pick whatever we feel like reading so
like right now reading book of dust I
Philip Pullman which is like the you
know I was going to ask you about
Philippa we're gonna come back to this
okay and so and then one of the groups
had a tradition but we've sort of fallen
out of it is that you would serve
something related to the books which was
funny like we read holes by Louis Sachar
and the person served donut holes or
like one time we read the little house
in the Big Woods and it was like you
know cornbread and apple pie and you
know red gingham tablecloth so that's
just sort of like a little fun thing you
could do if you felt like it um besides
who decides on the books to read we all
work it out like every book groups all
book groups have different ways and we
just sort of talk about it and and
everybody sort of says like yeah that
one sounds good so we don't really have
a we don't really have a particular
methodology for picking and sometimes
and you you
though now we're trying to pick a book
that at least everyone is talking about
it so it's like a book that's important
to read even if we don't like it or it's
a book that somebody has read and loves
and so they're like willing to say like
I really love this book because we don't
want to read something that is like no
one's gonna like but sometimes it's
worth reading a book just because it is
it's sort of of the moment and so you
want to know what is working right now
or what's what are people responding to
right now that's always kind of
interesting and then when you meet up
what does the meetup look like is it is
there by for ten minutes we're going to
do this for a half hour we're into this
the motto of the Qibla groups is no
guilt so you are encouraged to come even
if you haven't read the book if you
haven't been able to come for a year
because you've been too busy and then
you want to start coming again we
welcome you back at any time no
explanations necessary we talked about
the book as much or as little as we want
sometimes we talk about the book a lot
because there's a lot to say sometimes
it's like oh just you know you know it's
not that much and we talk about other
things that were more interested in so
it's very loose it's not it's not a
highly it's not a highly structured I
hear of it some book groups and I'm like
oh my gosh it sounds like a seminar you
know like you have to prepare and like
you have together they have like an
expert come talk I'm like no this is
just a bunch of people we just love it
so it's like everybody's sitting around
being like you know what did you think
you know and people who really know the
books so so you know it's like if you
want to talk about you know deep into
the Louie louisa may alcott cannon or
you know the Great Schism in the books
is twice in the groups is Twilight some
people like this but some people don't
like those books and so that's like you
know if I'm ever talking to somebody
who's thinking about the group I'm
always like well how do you feel about
it because you have to have an opinion
you know right but it's like anybody
who's in this area like has a viewpoint
it's like on the Twilight serious movies
it's like know you've got it you got to
have a view that's how we know you're
one of us you don't have to like you
have to think so I'd love for you to
clarify something for me because this is
this is something that
surprised me greatly and it may be a
misconception but I remember picking up
the golden compass and well I actually
bought all of what is it His Dark
Materials am I getting that right the
Philip Pullman series and I bought it I
remember I bought a paperback initially
and it was in the young adult section
and in my mind that meant easier reading
for younger readers and then I got into
this book and I had to constantly look
up nautical terms and vocabulary it was
a very very dense isn't the right word
but intellectually demanding book and I
thought to myself how in the hell could
say an 11 year old read this without a
good amount of assistance or a
dictionary and then a bookseller said to
me well it's young adult because the
protagonist is a young adult not because
the book is for young adults and I was
like really I wasn't sure about that's
it could you explain maybe your position
on that like what what what qualifies
something to be in the young adult genre
because I loved the Philip Pullman books
but they are certainly more demanding
intellectually than many of the
so-called adult books that I've read
yeah no and you raised a very
interesting question and one that we
talk about a lot and that nobody has a
good answer to which is what makes
something why a and sometimes it's just
a feel and and and a lot of times books
are put in way because the protagonists
are young adult like Jane Eyre has
started drifting into Yai will often see
it in Y a or like Catcher in the Rye
Catherine or I was not written for it to
be an idol book it's an adult book but
it sort of drifted there because the
protagonist is a teenager and I think
you're right sometimes it doesn't but
like then there's this I don't know if
you've read Black Swan green by David
Mitchell like that is clearly an adult
book but that protagonist is a teenager
I'm like it some day somebody gonna
decide that's a why a book so I think
you're right I think what what makes
something why or not is very much in the
eye of the beholder and it doesn't
necessarily mean that it's not
sophisticated or demanding and there's a
lot of books you know now there's a lot
of talk of crossover like are there
books that adults would read and I kind
with as much as I love children's
literature and young adult I kind of
wish that that people didn't see this
this split because I think a lot of
times adults don't read things that they
might very much enjoy because they think
well it's why a so it's it's not for me
and it's like these are these are really
you know these are really really great
books on their own terms so I'm with you
I don't I don't think that that's I
don't think that it that's what makes a
why a book because because there's many
books that are that have you know
teenage protagonists that you know I'm
just thinking of like title for the time
being by Ruth ozeki well half of like
one of the narrate there's two narrators
one of them is like a 15 year old girl
or something like that
that is not a why a book yeah so I it's
very it's very it's hard to define what
that is yeah it's so good right aren't
you glad you read it so oh it's
incredible yeah for people I was so
outraged when that movie came out and
it's just yeah absolutely horrible so
for swing again guys especially the
first book is so so good Mike group
thank you present somebody brought me a
Christmas ornament of a polar bear
wearing like a banner a royal banner and
I'm like I know I'm in the right group
because everybody showed it so every day
they're like look it's your Nick
garrison and I'm like of course it is
this is not just some random Golden
Compass such a good yes such a great
okay so so I'm gonna switch gears yet
again and I want to ask you about
accountability you were interviewed by a
friend of mine Chase Jarvis and believe
I'm getting this right you can certainly
fact check me but believe you said a lot
of people who are frustrated with
themselves just need accountability and
I was hoping you could expand on that
and maybe give us some examples of how
you or other people have used
accountability well that's gonna require
me to go into my four tendencies
framework so can I was doing this on you
oh yeah totally the four tendencies is
this personality framework that I
stumbled on basically when I was writing
better than before which is my book
about habit change because I kept
noticing patterns and how people could
and couldn't form habits that didn't
really wasn't really explained by
everything else that I was reading I was
like I don't get like what's going on
here it seemed like there was some
pattern there that had that was it
hadn't been identified and it almost
melted my brain like figuring this out
was definitely the most intellectually
challenging thing that I've ever done it
was the catalyst for it was a very
ordinary conversation where a friend of
mine said the weird thing about me is I
know I would be happier if I exercised
and when I was in high school I was on
the track team and I never missed track
practice so why can't I go running now
and I had heard many people say similar
things like that about my life but for
some reason when she said that I was
just electrified I was like I must
understand what is going on what's
different because it's the same person
it's the same behavior at one time it
was effortless for her now she can't do
it how do you explain that and that's
what led me to the four tendencies so an
accountability is a huge is we will get
to that
so the four tennessee's has it divides
people into upholders questioners
obligers and rebels depending on how you
respond to expectations I know this
sounds super boring but it gets really
to Z so so it has to do with how you
deal with outer expectations which are
things like a work deadline or request
from a friend and then also inner
expectations which is like your own
desire to keep into your so I was
loosing your own desire to write a novel
in your free time so there upholders
questioners obligors rebels app holders
readily meet outer and inner
expectations so they meet the work
deadline without much fuss they keep the
New Year's resolution without much fuss
they want to know what other people
expect from them but their expectations
for themselves are just as important
then there are questioners questioners
question all expectations they'll do it
if they think it makes sense so they're
turning everything into an inner
expectation if it meets their standard
they'll do it no problem if it fails
their standard they will resist and they
typically argue against anything
arbitrary inefficient irrational then
there are obligers and that's my friend
on the track team obligers readily meet
at our expectation
but they struggle to meet inner
expectations so they will meet the work
deadline but they're gonna have a lot of
trouble with the new year's resolution
and then there are rebels rebels resist
all expectations outer and inner alike
they want to do what they want to do in
their own way in their own time they can
do anything they want to do they can do
anything they choose to do but if you
ask or tell them to do something they're
very likely to resist and there's
there's a quiz on my site Gretchen Rubin
comm a free quiz and more than a million
people now have taken that quiz but most
people don't even need to take the quiz
they just hear that like little
introduction and they know what they are
and and this ends up making a huge
difference in how you most successfully
go through life and deal with other
people which are you I'm in a polder
which means that I readily meet outer
and inner expectations and now from the
from from the Knutson trip but I will it
seems like from the description you just
gave that it is by far best to be an
upholder there are their downsides to
being an upholder because it sounds
great if you're able to both follow your
inner and intrinsic motivators and
extrinsic motivators well there there's
a lot of there's a lot of great things
about being at a holder certainly it's a
small tendency ruble is the smallest
tendency and app holders only slightly
larger and one of the things the but all
of the tendencies have strengths and
weaknesses usually the strengths and the
weaknesses it's like two sides of the
same coin and when you look at who's the
happiest the healthiest the most
productive most creative it's the people
who have figured out how to harness the
strength of their tendency and offset
the weaknesses and limitations of their
tendency and some of the weaknesses and
limitations of app holders 1up holders
can they can be rigid like they will
lock into like a schedule or a priority
list and then it's like they're like
what do you mean we have to do something
different like they tend not to do well
where there's a lot of emphasis on being
flexible or where it's not clear what
expectations are or where it's ambiguous
what's expected of them or when things
change rapidly they can be they can have
tightening which is when the rules get
tighter which is like a friend of mine
who had a Fitbit you know was trying to
do 10,000 steps a day
he's like my wife was asleep in bed I
was locked myself in the bathroom
jogging away next to the toilet at 1:00
a.m. because I'm gonna get to my tent
you know like it could be good but
sometimes you can become kind of like
the you know the mindless bureaucrat of
your own paperwork as a we're like I was
doing physical therapy and my physical
therapist told me to do it twice a day
and then all of a sudden I found I was
doing it four times a day
I'm like maybe that's good but maybe
that's not good um and then they can
also seem very cold it's funny I the
other night I gave a talk and an
upholder somebody was like oh I seasoned
upholder like you and I think it's so
great to be in a polder what's the
downside and I said cuz they can seem
cold and this woman leaned said to me
she goes oh my gosh I am so cold because
upholders are like you know I know that
we've got guests coming to stay with us
at home this weekend but I got to go in
a 15 mile run cuz I'm training for the
marathon so you're gonna be on your own
cuz I got to go for my run or like you
know oh you're my colleague and our
reports are due tomorrow and you've
asked me if I can proofread your report
but I don't have time for that because I
got to finish my report my reports due
tomorrow to to an upholder that seems
appropriate I need to meet my inner
expectations as well as you know my
outer expectation of handing this in
tomorrow but to other people that can
seem cold because they're like well
can't you can't you give a little in
order to meet other expectations so
those are some of the downsides yeah so
for your friend who was able to run when
she was part of a track team but now as
I guess an obligor
doesn't have that external force what
type of action or structure what type of
action could she take or structure
because she create given that insight
well this goes back to your original
question which is about accountability
that is the answer for obligers and I
would save everything related to the
four tendencies this is the most
important idea that's helped the most
people figure out kind of the hidden
patterns of their nature which is that
if you're an obligor by definition you
can meet you can easily meet your
meeting outer expectations but
struggling to meet interactive occasions
the solution the way to fix this the
very concrete and straightforward
solution is outer accountability outer
accountability can work for other
tendencies it is a sin
for obligers if you want to read more
join a book group if you want to
exercise more join a class where they
take attendance work out with a trainer
work out with a friend who's gonna be
annoyed if you don't show up take your
dog for a run every morning and he's
gonna be so disappointed if he doesn't
go for a run plus he's gonna tear up the
living room some obligors can use things
like their future self like well now
Gretchen doesn't want to go for a run
but future Gretchen's gonna be so
disappointed if I break the chain I've
been going so I've been doing so well I
need to do it because food for future
Gretchen obligers very dramatically and
what kind of accountability structures
work for them because like some for some
obligors
paying for something makes them very
likely to feel accountable for other
obligors it's almost like it makes them
feel like they're off the hook like oh I
paid for it so that's like the same as
doing it you're like no it's really not
but so but that is the thing when you're
an obligor you want to feel like figure
out well how can I create a structure of
an outer accountability around inner
expectations this is true even for
self-care this is a word huge tip-off if
somebody starts talking about self-care
I'm like Bing Bing Bing
you're an obligor or if you're somebody
who's like well you know I I don't have
time to exercise because I give 110
percent to my clients like you're an
obligor
cuz you're saying I can't meet an inner
expectation because I'm always meeting
outer expectations now you might pride
yourself on that and think oh I'm such a
badass of course I I'm always seeing
patients I'm always at the hospital I
never have time to like cook you know I
never have time to have a healthy meal
because I'm always eating out of the
vending machines because I'm I work so
hard at the hospital I do everything for
my patient it's like okay well you're an
obligor so given that if you do decide
that you want to exercise or eat
healthfully or write a novel or practice
meditation or whatever how could you
imagine systems of outer accountability
that would permit you to follow through
with that that inner aim that you have
for yourself and some types of lasers
don't like the fact that they're reliant
on outer accountability they feel like
somehow it's weak like who cares it's
it's the biggest tendency it's the one
that most the most people belong to for
both men and women a lot of people are
in the same boat who cares how it what
you have to do to get there just figure
out what works for you
you know outer accountability works use
it yeah totally it's it doesn't have to
be depressing it can just be useful I
mean if you if you look at the
psychology and the incentives involved
I mean I've for instance I mean I've
seen people who have used to great
effect services or sites like dietbet
calm or you're putting money into a
betting pool or stick STI ck calm or
others where you're provided with a
framework for holding yourself
accountable whether that results in
financial loss if you don't hit the
goals or if you have people who are
effectively referees who hold you
accountable like you mentioned do you
you mentioned New Year's resolution a
few minutes ago do you set New Year's
resolutions for yourself is that a
practice that you have kind of my job is
to have I feel like I'm like resolving
constantly um so I don't really make new
year's resolutions in the same way on
the happier podcast Alyssa than I did
this thing called 18 for 2018 and that
wasn't really like resolutions it was
more like 18 things you want to get done
in 2018 so that was like a different you
know there's all then there's like the
way I want one thing I do I've done many
times it's pick a one word theme for the
year which like is it's again a
different take at the New Year's
resolution where you're like my like
this year my my word is delegation and
I've had it in other words be like you
know like there's you know repurposing
you know we're on it setting a theme for
the year my sister's one year was hot
wheels cuz she wanted to get a new car
but but I don't really make traditional
New Year's resolutions anymore partly
because I do make so many resolutions
sort of as part of my ongoing experiment
and happiness and good habits if but
something occurs to me I usually like
try it right away because just you know
for the fun of it so delegation is your
I like this idea of a one word theme for
the year so delegation is your theme for
2018 yeah because yeah I realize I need
to delegate more so I was going to ask
how how does that then get translated
into sort of actions things with
deadlines next steps and so on what what
is your a process from from the point of
identifying that and naming it to
starting to implement
and make sure that it's translated into
real life what does that look like well
for me it's it's asking myself the
question what is it that I do that
someone else can do they're sitting
there are many things that I do that no
one else could do but there are some
things that I do that other people could
do and I need to be more disciplined and
identifying that and delegating it
partly it's just like in any one moment
it's easier to just do it myself
it's like faster to just do it myself
until like sit down and figure out well
who could do it instead and how could I
delegate it or maybe I shouldn't do it
at all or you know it's just easy and
that's part of being in a polder it's
easier for me to just execute than to
step back and be like well why should I
do this and is there a better way
that's what questioners are good at and
so I want to do that and then like last
year my my theme was repurposing but I
realized and I did a very bad job living
up to that theme and I'm like that's
because I need to delegate repurposing
which is I need to find like someone who
I can ask like to go through you know
I'm a tremendous archive of stuff but I
always want to just be creating a new
thing but I have all this stuff that I
could make something cool out of and say
like say to somebody go through look at
all my stuff and pull out everything
related to self-knowledge and put it in
some kind of form and then I'll go
through it and and polish it and tinker
with it and make it into something
really cool but if you would just go
through and do that then my my work
would take a fraction of the time it
would just be the fun part that only I
can do because you know instead of me
thinking keep thinking oh I should go
through and like cut and paste it would
sort of be fun but somebody else can do
that so I need so I'm trying to figure
that out how exactly that's gonna what
form that will take it doesn't come
naturally to me so it's going to be it's
going to be a struggle are there any any
particular low-hanging fruit or first
candidates that you're that you're
thinking of experimenting with
delegating well I'd see that's a very
good question because I feel like I
could do all these sort of little books
and I need to sit down and decide well
which one would be the most fun for me
and for other and for readers like I
have all these like one sentence
aphorisms which I love one sentence
aphorisms and they're sort of sprinkle
and like secrets of adulthood and
they're sprinkled
all over the place but I have to sit
down and think like is this something
that would be a good book is this a book
is this not a book is there something
else it should be you know that's like
that's the work that only I can do but
then once I decide like well what's that
priority then I can start thinking about
it yeah so it's a hole it's it's a big
thing it's not it's not like something
it's not like you know pick up my
clothes every night before I go to bed
instead of leaving them in a giant pile
on the end of the you know at the chair
at the end of the bed which is another
one of my resolutions but that that's
like easy to execute right this one
there's like lots of moving pieces that
are very uncomfortable for me to ponder
yeah huh well how will you go how will
you go about making that process process
easier for yourself or I mean I think
that a lot of people listening certainly
will feel a similar pain in terms of
their historic lack of delegation are
there any people or systems that you're
going to rely on to help you with the
getting better at delegation well I
think it's I think I have to I think it
has to come from my own mind so I think
it's about examining my work process and
thinking well what is it that I can do
what is it that I should do that no one
else can do I'm thinking about that
that's what I need to sit down yeah yeah
yeah everything from handling email to
you know all that stuff mm-hmm
so I know we we don't have to too much
time left but I'd love to ask you some
of my suppose usual kind of rapid-fire
questions completely honest how you'd
answer some of them and one is one is
related to failure so is there any
particular failure of yours that you can
think of that set the stage for a later
success or a favorite or favorite
failure of yours so to speak that you
learned a lot from or steered you in a
different direction absolutely
absolutely so I wrote a book which I
love I love all my books called 40 ways
to look at JFK and as they say in the
industry it did not find its
audience so nobody bought this book
nobody was interested in this book and
but what it taught me that was it so it
was a very it was a failure I didn't
they didn't even make it into a
paperback so that was a that was my only
book that's only exists in her back for
him um and but what I learned was I had
this incredible feeling of helplessness
that here I was I had poured my heart
into a book I really thought it was good
and I was totally dependent on others to
shine a spotlight on it like there was
nothing I could do to try to let people
know that the book was there now maybe
they weren't interested but I couldn't
even try to interest them in it I had no
tools and it was just at this time that
everything was become all the tools that
now exist online were just becoming
accessible enough to people who are very
untechnical like me things like having a
blog and and I had already started
working on the Happiness Project and one
of the kind of and the idea of the
Happiness Project is I was test driving
all these things that people tell you
about how you can be happier and one of
the things that the research keeps
showing is that novelty and challenge
make people happier and I thought well
that's not true for me I like mastery
and familiarity but I have to do
something because the whole point of the
book is and I'm gonna do this experiment
so I'm like well I'll do something novel
in challenging I'll start a blog
well I quickly realized that the blog
which I started thinking that it would
be like my gratitude journal and I would
quickly abandon it because it wouldn't
work which I did with my gratitude
journal but the but I that I really
enjoyed the blog it did well and I
realized that it was solving this
problem that I had felt before which was
I have no way to connect directly to
readers and so I feel like if that's if
I hadn't had if I hadn't had that
failure I wouldn't have I don't think I
would have had as much excitement and
interest in the blog because I wouldn't
have understood how valuable it is to
connect with readers it's one of the
reasons I love having a podcast it's one
of the reasons that I like I love using
social media like I love connecting with
listeners and viewers and readers about
the subjects that I'm interested in I
get immense value from it because I get
all kinds of examples and questions and
illustrations and people are like my
research assistants they'll send me
links to research and you know anything
they think you know connect
so the things that I'm obsessed with I'm
so it's enormous ly valuable to me but I
don't know if that book had done fine I
don't know that I would have realized
the value of it because I would have
been like oh I'll just write a good book
and people will just naturally know
about it and it's like but now with like
shrinking you know coverage in
traditional media you know there's fewer
now looks like indie bookstores are kind
of coming back but for a while it was
really scary for indie bookstores like I
was I thought I really do want to be
able to connect with people myself just
like with my own steam rather than
depending on gatekeepers like for sure
I don't get a book review then this book
essentially doesn't exist in the public
mind or you know once it's not in the
front table then no one will ever see it
again it will never be heard from again
so that was a failure that had enormous
consequences for me it did not feel it
did not feel like a like a like a
hopeful failure at the time but looking
back it was a lucky failure for sure
what's up what's software platform do
you use for your blog uh
WordPress yeah yeah WordPress is
interesting I mean for a host of reasons
write both email podcasting and
platforms like WordPress are really I'm
also on WordPress and have been since
day one even before I became involved
with automatic later the company handles
wordpress.com but the the benefit in say
an open-source platform or something
that can be ported from one place in the
case of email from one say email service
provider to another is that your
audience travels with you right in this
makes me think of a conversation that I
had long ago with someone who had a
multi-million dollar business based on
Facebook and I think Facebook is
incredibly valuable for a lot of things
however yeah when your access and reach
to your audiences depend on an algorithm
that is 100 percent outside of your
control I asked him what it was like to
have a business based on Facebook and he
said it's like owning the most
profitable McDonald's in the world on
top of an active volcano
this is something certainly with books I
mean the vast majority this is changing
but many authors and certainly most
publishers have no means of
communication with their readers
whatsoever its are really really
important so this this then is a
follow-up question and you might have to
pick something else because I think this
what you just said could be an answer
but what is one of the best or most
worthwhile investments you've ever made
could be money time energy anything at
all hmm I mean like I mean I just keep
thinking laptop but that's so basic and
so long ago it doesn't even really count
that's skill development is there any
particular learning up like podcast I
mean that's a whole separate skill yeah
that was huge like entering into that
world was a huge huge thing yeah how did
you how did you learn I mean what what
because you have a you have a popular
podcast certainly you were coming in
with an advantage as I did with an
audience for your books but how did you
think about learning to podcast well I
did something which is like one of my
favorite things to do which was I was
like I'm gonna have a manifesto like I'm
really into sort of like taking ideas
and trying to distill them so I went
around and talked to as many people I
could find who either created a podcast
or worked in podcasting or just loved
forecast and I asked them like what like
how do you even think about it and would
hear what they talk and then whenever
they would say something that I was like
okay
it makes the manifesto you know and so
like one of them like one thing that
made the manifesto which i think about
all the time is to be consistent and
also surprised and i think about that
all the time like there has to be
consistency but then you also have to
break it up you know instead of you're
like lis let the outside world into your
podcast you know you don't want it to
become too insular um you have new
people in your podcasts all the time but
for us it's mostly me and my sister so
it's like you don't want it to start
feeling claustrophobic so how do you
outside world in um just as a just to
hit pause for a second how do you do
that because it could quickly become
just all inside baseball right for
Langton listeners well one thing is
have interviews but very sporadically so
not nearly you know it's like every
maybe fifth episode even that often so
that's one way to get in sometimes our
producer will come in and like like just
like make a comment so you're like oh
yeah they're in a they're in you know
there is like other people around often
we try to have clips from like
televisions or movies if those are if
those are relevant or you know music if
there's something like that or you know
even sound effects or just something so
like so that the sound is changing so
that's one thing it's so for me that was
that's very helpful it's sort of like
okay I'm I'm not just like having coffee
with somebody and having them tell me
about their podcast I'm like I'm looking
for those gems that are like the
takeaways or like one thing is fans are
great but a community is that is is
better so how do you change it how do
you change fans into a community like
that's a question that we still are
thinking about all the time this is an
aspirational manifesto it's not what we
do it's what we try to do yeah how have
you thought about turning your listeners
into a community well one thing that we
do a lot of is we have tons of listener
content so like like for the holidays
for instance we we were like okay send
us your best holiday hack like some
quick easy thing to make the holidays
easier whether that's about entertaining
or your Christmas card list or you know
buying gifts or dealing with your
difficult relatives or like traveling
whatever it is and then we would go
through and have like oh here all these
things from our community or like I did
this thing which worked out really well
we're on someone had emailed to ask if I
had any because I love quotations so
much I like a quotation newsletter where
he send out a quotation every day
a happiness quotation um said do you
have any good ideas for funeral readings
or memorial readings because I have to
like I have to like there's I have to go
to a funeral and I need readings and I
was like this is a great question for
everyone like and so it was like a whole
community project people would send in
their favorites and then I made a PDF
and then it's just something that people
can ask for like do you want the funeral
the readings for a funeral sermon and
when you need that it's like it's
really helpful to get like a 20-page
document that's and it's from everybody
or like we did a thing on Spotify about
you know how like when you're feeling
blue most people have like a song that
they there's like their go-to song to
make themselves cheer up right so we ask
people to like submit their songs and
it's like now it's like dozens and
dozens and dozens of hours on Spotify if
everybody's like this is my go-to song
so it's like the happiest most
energizing playlists but everybody built
it together and says that how did they
make those submissions by email or
voicemail I mean then we had a meet-up
we've only had one Meetup it was really
it was great but it was like it's it's a
thing to pull that off like where do you
do it how do you organize that how do
you get people to RSVP so we need to
work on that we've done a couple live
events those are super fun we want to do
more of those because we do feel like
that's like the great community thing
because there's like everybody's there
together and and alissa my sister has
another podcast for own and they have a
very active Facebook group happier in
Hollywood we have not done that with
happier but I know that that's something
that a lot that can be really really
effective too so but it's again it's
like everybody would everybody would
have a different answer for like
depending on what they're interested in
when they're good at what their audience
is interested in what their content is
but it's a good question which is how do
you turn fans into a community know that
it's like fun to talk about is the
manifesto written out sort of like Jerry
Maguire so you have how long is it it's
like 15 items I think now okay so it's
it's really like the 15 commandments of
sorts yeah part of it is like to keep it
succinct ya know it's like 15 one-liners
have you shared it anywhere winter
that's one of ours um yeah yeah no I
gave a whole talk about it like okay
great
no it's public if anybody wants it just
email me and I'll send you my podcasting
my podcast manifesto I love a manifesto
I don't have its manifesto I how about
happiness manifesto I love these frame
where I like distilling things it's like
it's like for me that's like so many
it's like some people like to write
haiku I like to write manifestos no I
don't
destroy your inbox which is entirely
possible maybe you have some system for
avoiding inbox deluge but when you said
people can email you if they wanted to
find or read the habit manifesto or the
podcasting manifesto how would you
suggest they find it I mean certainly
they could search your name and then
fill in the blank manifesto on Google or
elsewhere but right on my website
they're there they're there on my
website and the resources if they wanted
that yeah perfect
you mention quotations if you could have
a giant billboard anywhere
metaphorically speaking right getting a
message out to millions or billions yeah
so it could be it could be a few words
it could be a paragraph doesn't really
matter it could be some saying of yours
or it could be another quote from from
someone else what might you put on it
well I think of everything that I have
ever if it was gonna be a quote for me
everything that I have ever written
there's clearly one sentence that is the
sentence that that is the most
meaningful to people and that is the
days are long but the years are short
that is I feel like for many people that
is like the most help that's like the
thing that's quoted back to me the most
like this idea that you know getting
sometimes getting from mourning tonight
feels interminable but then you're like
where did 2017 go like do I even
remember March 2017 like what even
happened like it just flashed by so to
remember that to remember that and if
you are there any quotes that you use as
routinely for it I have certain quotes
that I revisit often or that I have in
my home somewhere then I will see them
often
are there any quotes that you might put
on a billboard for yourself one is from
Robert Louis Stevenson
there is no duty we so under eight as
the duty of being happy which i think is
great and then there's one from Thomas
Merton and I'm not sure I'm going to get
it 100
accurate but he said essentially I am
finally coming to the conclusion that my
highest ambition is to be what I already
am oh I like that
hmm I like that a lot I may not have
that word perfect but I know that's the
gist of it yeah the how did you find an
interest and we only have you don't
we'll take a few more minutes but in in
Cohen's and these types of
thought-provoking statements or
questions perhaps without an answer
right that's that's kind of part of the
exercise and in some respects but I mean
for instance one of my favorite quotes
which is is certainly at times or most
of the time quite a head-scratcher which
is roomy which is that which you seek is
seeking you that's very much like one of
my favorite columns which is Samuel
Johnson quoting a Spanish proverb that
said he who would find the wealth of the
Indies must bring the wealth of the
Indies with him
same same idea so why is very powerful
what which what itch do those scratch
free or how did you why the interest I
guess I like this sort of escape from
logic or like the way the they're
usually like the perfection of the idea
or like the the elusiveness of it like
right now one of my one of my weird
obsessions that I'm into is color I'm
like really really obsessed with color
and I have a ton of color Cohen's that
are Cohen's that are only about color
and like oh here's one that somebody
actually said to me in real life wait
what was it because she said I walked
into a store and I said I want to buy
this blue chair and the clerk said
everybody says it's blue but that chair
is actually brown is to chair blue or
brown yeah right what color do you use
to paint an object that's transparent
mm-hmm what why the interesting color
how did this come I am oh so the way
came about was so on the happier podcast
ELISA and I we always have a try this at
home
just like a small concrete thing that
you can do in your everyday life to make
yourself happier and so we are tried
this at home when we CLIs to pick a
signature color and ironically neither
Elizabeth nor I has ever been able to
pick a signature color but we put it out
there you said sinister signature Oh
signature got it yeah but and so and and
and I thought this was sort of a fun
playful thing and again it's a way to
tap into like the power of the moment in
your environment and but we got so many
impassioned delighted the responses from
people and also like so many pictures
and I mean there were crazy stories like
a woman who said that her mother had
really been into the color red and also
kind of the Southwest look that when she
died they got a red Southwest designed
urn for her ashes I mean these are
people really taking it all the way and
it just got me thinking about color and
you know as I said before I'm not a
visual person I can only get through the
visual through words and so I started
reading more and more about color it
turns out there's like this giant
literature about color there's a French
historian of color who's slowly working
his way he had a book called black a
book called green had a book called blue
red just came out this year
clearly awaiting yellow there and then
all these kind of crazy interesting
philosophical books about it anyway um
once I got into it it's just like I
couldn't stop
um and now I'm doing some like weird
little thing writing kind of like a
weird little book called my color
pilgrimage which I have no idea what
that's even gonna be but I couldn't help
myself I just had to do it felt that
compulsion again sure I did and so part
of it is is these cones like could a
painting include a light yellow that's
lighter than a dark white can light
yellow be light can light yellow be
lighter than dark white I like that oh
here's here's an interesting question
now this is like color questions do you
think dragons are green or red I well I
would probably go with green personally
interesting that is historically the
color of dragons I would always say red
so but this is like what color unicorns
they can
be any color we want because they don't
really exist but it's interesting like
I'm like to me it's like of course
they're red it's like I'm like I didn't
even know that was a question that
anybody would have do you believe in cut
like how can a color be a chromatic
black white and gray are considered a
chromatic colors they're non color
colors how can you have a non color
color is black a color I say yes black
its color so anyway so on the theme of
black just since you're going down this
rabbit hole I have a recommendation for
you a very short and exceptionally weird
book that may that may have a that may
have a few paragraphs you would fall in
love with but it's something you can
read in an afternoon really easily it's
called in praise of shadows it's an
essay on Japanese aesthetics by it opens
with his like brilliant invocation of
the like the outhouse that's right yeah
and talk talks about how Japanese
aesthetics or and also color right the
use of gold were designed to reflect
light in very dim environments so
contemporary in contemporary design when
you have traditional Japanese color
palettes in brightly lit rooms it
doesn't work and it seems very gaudy it
just has one point right that hence the
title in praise of shadows I'm so glad
that you mention it because I read it
and remembered thinking there's a lot
about that book that it's very deeply
weird but I wasn't obsessed with color
at the time so I didn't read it through
the lens of color and so now I want to
go back and reread it because it is a
very it's a very it's a controversial
book in many ways super super weird yeah
super weird and but but you know
sometimes you read something and you're
just not in the same place to like I bet
now I would read it with a whole
different eye so I'm so glad that you
mentioned it because I will be checking
it out of the library tomorrow I'm going
to the library tomorrow and yes I know
exactly where it is because I have a
copy so that's great yeah no the
Japanese are interesting because they
four basic colors black white and a
particular blue in a particular red
that's like their core color which is
which it's not yeah it's a different
approach
well what's Japan I remember those one
of the first places I realized my first
extended trip abroad was in Japan as an
exchange student for a year so I really
went from zero to sixty very very
quickly in terms of culture shock and I
remember one of the conversations that
just made my mind sort of tilt its head
like a confused Labrador was the fact
that the wall what we would consider the
green go signal at a sidewalk Japanese
people call blue even though they have a
separate word for green and I would ask
them that's a very recent introduction
into their vocabulary that's part of why
I don't know I don't know when it was
when it was introduced but the I mean
they have a clear delineation if you
look at it on paper you could say this
is green this is blue and you would have
agreement and then you look at the
crosswalk sign and you say it's green
they say no you mean it's blue and then
it was really a trip for me just a
mental trip to realize how socially
conditioned our even our perception of
color is right which you would expect is
sensory input converted by these rods
and cones at the back of the eye into
this objective fill-in-the-blank color
but it's just not the case it doesn't
seem in Russia they have a word just
like we have a word for light red is
pink and we don't really say things
they're light red we would call it pink
they have a word like that for light
blue they have a whole separate word for
it and and it's interesting in it
actually when you look at the brain
function of people who speak Russian and
their color identification it's
different because when when you have a
distinction like that built into your
language it does change the way at the
speed particularly with which it you
could perceive these things so it is
it's very like and I just was reading
today that the word orange like didn't
exist until literally oranges came into
the marketplace in Europe because they
just said they just said
red they didn't have like a special word
for it because there just was I guess
there just wasn't enough need for it and
then when the oranges came they were
like oh we're gonna and that's why it's
called orange because it's literally
from oranges because that's when they
began to identify the color yes so
there's all sorts of crazy color history
think what I'm gonna do with this I
don't know but yeah so that you're that
Japanese it's a very different way of
perceiving color I'll give you one more
recommendation that is going to make
sense to like a fraction of 1% of people
out there but that's okay which is look
look into the experimentalists who are
creating hardware devices for sensory
substitution experiments so that if
people want to hear colors or feel site
there are hardware devices that have
been created to help people to
experience this in various experimental
designs my friend Edie cook who's a
memory champion and very fascinating guy
has done a lot of experimentation with
this but that could feed into your
rabbit hall of of color that's right
yeah it's using computers and hardware
to enable synesthesia in non-synesthetes
so to speak I'm angry so on completely
separate note what what try this at home
has had the strongest response to date
of any that you've done with your oh my
gosh so many I don't know two years or
any that come to mind that had huge
responses from your audiences well this
18 for 2018 people are really responding
to that has been super fun
what are some other big ones I'm just
going blank that's okay like we just
there's just so many you don't want you
know one thing though it's we didn't do
it as a try this at home but it's
something that we keep hearing about
over and over and over again it's
it really people respond to is to ELISA
the night where we're sisters and our
parents live in Kansas City and my
mother made this suggestion she was like
you know you know how it is and
everybody has remarked on this that like
if you see somebody every day you have
tons to talk about with them but if you
see people like once every six months
it's like how are you fine how are you
like it's hard to make conversation
right so my mother said let's just email
each other with this like the boring
details of everyday life and we
instantly realized that this was a
genius idea and so in our family my
nuclear might you know my my my sister
and my parents the four of us we will
send these periodic updates like say
maybe every four or five days that just
says update that's the title and it's
just like the most boring thing it's
like my mother will be like I'm getting
my hair colored later today or I'll be
like Eleanor's really annoyed because
barnaby tracked snow all over her bed
you know it's this like the most mundane
things are like oh I'm leaving tomorrow
for London it should be really fun I'm
seeing my friend Delia do you remember
her she was my roommate after college
and and there's no it's okay to be
boring that is the motto of update and
but what we find is that it dramatically
increases our feeling of connection with
each other because when you know that
Monday and stuff and then also it's good
if there's like kids because my parents
can say oh I heard that you had a
Halloween party at school or like they
know what's going on in a much more kind
of day-to-day way and so many people
have set and some people do this as like
a group text I like that cool people
have set up private groups on Facebook
people do it all different ways but the
idea is it's better to have frequent
boring mundane communications than to
save it up for like when there's
something big to report because that's
not how relationships work relationships
really thrive on really being in touch
with people and and also nobody ever
responds to update so there's no guilt
there's no like oh now I have to like a
hat craft a witty response or like now I
have to do in - it's just like you just
put it out there and usually nobody even
responds and because it's like let's
keep this easy so we can do it you know
I think sometimes people want to have
like let's start some beautiful thing
where we like write handwritten letters
on parchment and mail it to each other
you know like now I'm not going to do
that so that's something that's
interesting well for us and we thought
it was sort of our it
syncretic family but like over time like
that's the thing where people are like
tell me again what was that thing with
update because I want to do that that's
something that really love huh yeah so
that's two more questions for you this
is I suppose pretty self self
explanatory when you feel overwhelmed or
unfocused or feel like you've lost your
focus temporarily what do you do
oh I reread a children's book reason is
there go to oh I get a million go twos
but like in fact like Harry Potter I was
like I have to hold back Harry Potter
do not let myself reread and reread it
reread it I have to hold it for a moment
of need and so when I got the edits back
from my editor for my book better than
before it was like I'm like and now I'm
gonna start rereading Harry Potter I
need it now because I'm processing all
of this stuff but no I have like a
thousand books you know Edward eager
list is n right I mean Philip Pullman I
mean I got a million
I got a huge library full but I love
rereading I love rereading adult books
too I reread adult books all the time
but there's something very comforting
about children's books particularly CS
lewis i mean how many times have i read
the line in which the Wardrobe I mean
easily could be forty could be more Wow
but yes like oh I'm like oh yeah I need
in fact it's almost to tell it's funny
that you ask that cuz it's almost like
sometimes I know I'm feeling overwhelmed
without really I'm like oh I'm reading
the dark is rising by Susan Cooper again
I wonder if I'm feeling a little bit
stressed out it's sometimes like my
reading choice it tells me more about my
emotional state than I mean that's your
divining rod do you read the entire book
if you're for instance you get your
edits back on your own book do you just
need a minimum effective dose a little
like a vein hit of you know or two
chapters and you're good or do you end
up reading the whole book how does that
typically run its course it kind of
depends
sometimes you know and some of these
books are so short you can practically
read the whole thing you know if you've
read it before if you've read it 40
times before you can work through that
thing pretty fast um it depends you know
sometimes I'll just reread like my
favorite couple of favorite parts that
are comforting you don't work it's a
really good book or book that I haven't
read in a long time I might read the
whole thing some books are complicated
you know and but but I do try to be
careful not to read them so often that I
wear them out because you can do that
with a book and kind of lose the
pleasure of it because it's too familiar
I kind of like wore out Rahl doll early
so I don't read I don't really rolled
all very much now cuz I'm like I just
know his books so well that they kind of
don't have any pleasure for me anymore
what is a short children's or a young
adult book that you would recommend
almost everybody give a shot something
that can be read in my or weekend I
would say the midnight fox my Betsy
Byars it's like that's like a middle
grade book are you talking like a middle
grade book or more like a why a book
anybody anybody male or female adult or
child it is it's just a perfect book
great it's funny it's thoughtful
it's got great characters it's it's a
great book so the midnight Fox and then
for Y a for young adult what would you
what would your nomination be why it
gets trickier what is a y one day this
pain will be useful to you is an amazing
character in a beautifully written book
I would highly recommend that let's see
what is another one I mean then there
are ones that everybody knows about like
wonder that is that is an amazing book
and but maybe that's even middle grade I
don't know what they consider that I
would say the Golden Compass for sure
it's so unbelievably good and the
characters are so unbelievably
compelling and the world is so
unbelievably interesting and it's like
nothing you've ever read before and it's
like very it's like connected to the
deepest core of thinking and philosophy
that is a towering masterpiece yeah so
it said the Golden Compass by Philip
Pullman it's but it's scary
and it's challenging yeah yeah it's not
you to read out loud to your
six-year-old for sure especially the
later call here yeah what adult books
book or books have you reread the most
or reread or reread a lot because you
mentioned there are some adult books
that you've read read a lot like you
know probably like I've reread a lot of
nonfiction like a book I love that I
have read so many times as memories
dreams reflections by Carl Jung into the
wild by Jon Krakauer selected essays by
George Orwell or there's I have my
favorite essays that I will go read some
of them are in like the short short
collections some are Samuel Johnson
essays I read and reread a lot I loved
Samuel Johnson I read it I love Virginia
Woolf she kind of blows my head open so
I it's hard for me to reread it I'll
often reread her nonfiction same thing
with Flannery O'Connor Flannery
O'Connor's fiction is so kind of it
really is so mind-blowing that I almost
can't take it I have to be in a very
particular emotional wise blood but I
reread her nonfiction a lot because I
love her nonfiction I love her voice and
it's a lot easier to take so I have a
for rereading I probably reread
nonfiction a lot and then I love like
Robertson Davies Jane Austen sometimes
if I want to reread a novel I'll read
something like that Wow see you you have
an you have a very very impressive level
of output in terms of creation in the
world how many hours a week or day or a
month however you want to slice it do
you spend reading you know I don't know
and that is a great question because
every week on Facebook I post a picture
of the books that I've read that week
and I don't have any kind of I don't do
any editorializing or any explanation
but if I've read it I put a picture of
it and if I don't like a book I don't
finish it so if you know if so if I
finished it means I liked it well enough
to finish it
and every week I have read books but I
feel like I spend no time reading and
I'm constantly thinking to myself how
can I find more time to read how can I
find more time to go to the library how
can I find more time to like you know
have four hundred and fifty-seven books
in my library list in my phone how I
just need to make more time to read and
yet I must have reading and then I do a
lot of research I'm always taking notes
off things I've read so to me it is a
mystery and I know I should do time
logging like Laura Vander cam says and
like really write it down like a lawyer
and figure out where is my time we're at
when am I reading sounds stressful to me
I don't know I really I don't know how
much time I read it probably varies
tremendously oh but here's a great tip
but somebody told me and this has really
changed my reading she said to me that
if you're a person who travels a lot for
work as Tim you and I both do her rule
is she only reads for pleasure when
she's traveling for work so from the
minute that she gets to the airport to
the minute but she'll work in the hotel
room to the minute that she gets to the
hotel she will only read for fun on the
plane in the airport there's no
expectation that she's gonna work and to
me this has dramatically improved my
experience of travel and I've got an
amazing amount of reading done because
it wasn't even like I was getting that
much work done but I felt like I should
be working so Trisha now I've been yeah
I'm just like you know what like I read
Manhattan Beach Jennifer Egan like I had
a flight like a flight from London plus
I had all the time in Heathrow I'm like
I read the whole book from the time that
I left to the time that I landed I think
I only had a few chapters left by the
time because I just read the whole time
it's so satisfying yeah I'm and and
you're like traveling so much better
because I really look forward to having
that really concentrated reading time
and and I wasn't getting much work done
anyway I mean honestly I just wasn't I
was you know kind of I think some people
can really really work on airplanes and
if you do then maybe you want to do that
because it's a really good place for you
to work but I was not getting quality
worked on an airplane well we could talk
for hours and hours and hours I but
we'll save that for around two is there
anything that you would like to
well first inform us where can people
learn more about you what you're up to
where would you like them to say hi and
so on
if you go to Gretchen Rubin comm that's
are you bi n comm there's all sorts of
information resources videos contact and
if you contact me through my blog it
really does come straight through to me
you can see my podcast learn more about
my books like there's way more there
than you would ever want to know read
about color yeah yeah go to Gretchen
Rubicon or the part of the podcast is
called happier with Gretchen Rubin if
you're looking for a podcast perfect and
is there anything you would like to
close with any parting comments
suggestions next steps try this at home
anything that people can can do to
change the behavior change their
thoughts whatever you want to wrap up
with any final thoughts I just instead
can I ask you a question yes of course
you know what your tendency is what do
you think you're tended to okay you
would mention it and we moved on yeah
well I didn't want to make it you know I
feel like this entire podcast is pretty
self-indulgent and so I was hoping I
wasn't going to take it there but I will
say yeah so I definitely it was
questioner right or questioning was that
the was that one of those ones that
they'll meet in our expectations but if
if they think they make sense they'll
meet an expectation but if they think it
doesn't make sense if it's arbitrary or
inefficient yep
pushback I think that's me and means
what is that now I'm curious to know
what are the downsides of that and how
can one mitigate against the downsides
the downsides for questioners is
sometimes they can drain and overwhelm
people with their questioning like
everybody else is like why are we still
talking about this and you're like but
what about this and what about this and
what about this so to the questioner
this is like of course we can't move
forward until all these questions are
answered because why would we waste our
time and our energy if we don't think
it's the right thing to do
but to other people like if you're in a
team or something sometimes people you
know start getting exasperated and
exhausted because they feel
it's too many questions on some
questioners experience analysis
paralysis which is when they want
perfect information and so it's hard to
make a decision or move forward because
they're like it's like you know what's
the best you know email service provider
you don't how I could do more and more
and more research on that and like oh
maybe I should do this maybe I should do
that or you know I want to buy a bike
what's the best bike and so it's it can
be hard some some question my husband's
a questioner he never really experiences
this as far as I can tell but for some
questioners it's something where they
need to figure out how to contain that
so that they can move forward and and
funnily enough often analysis paralysis
seems to be about little things not big
things like it's like a person might not
have any trouble deciding to switch
careers but if they were trying to
decide what kind of tent to buy that
could really hold them up it seems to be
like something those kinds of things
seem to be the the things that become
the stumbling block and then also for
questioners and this is something really
about a problem that questioners have
with others is that if you're a
questioner they can sometimes be
perceived as by others as being
disrespectful insubordinate undermining
of authority questioning someone
judgment not it seem players so if
you're a questioner child and you say to
your teacher why should I have to
memorize the multiplication tables if I
can just look it up on my phone just as
quickly and more accurately and the
teachers like because I say so or
because all 10 year-olds have to do it
or because that's what you do in 4th
grade the questioner is gonna be like
well that's ridiculous and that's no
answer and I'm not gonna do it and so
they're perceived by the child but the
teachers being disrespectful or
uncooperative but to the questioner this
makes perfect sense
or you get a thin-skinned boss and the
boss is like your questions make me feel
like you're rejecting my authority
you're undermining my judgment you're
not a team player I don't want to work
with you and it's like but to the
question and they're like well this is
how I add value to the team I'm you know
how can I be a better team player but
then to say to everybody this is a crazy
idea why would we ever do this it's a
big waste of our time but to the boss
they're like I don't like that and so
partly it's for questioners to realize
how they can ask questions in a way that
seem constructive rather than making
other people feel sort of defensive or
because there's huge value for to the
questioners questioning and in some
places some and work environments or
whatever it's very rewarded and you know
and praised but then some places it's
like hey listen we're here to do what
corporate says and it's not interesting
for us to hear you complain about why
you don't think it's a good idea like
get with the program stop interrupting
the meetings like you're keeping every
you know so if you're questioning you
maybe want to know well what kind of
environment are you getting into because
one might suit you better than another I
don't know just this resonate with you
is this strict word oh yeah totally
no I mean I got in so much trouble in
school consistently I was actually put
at the bad table in kindergarten which
my teacher then it was called the bad
table I was putting well she did a lot
of things you couldn't do today I mean
she she made me eat soap in front of the
class because I refused to learn the
alphabet because she never explained why
I had to memorize these arbitrary shapes
until this is Vince key in first grade
then redeemed me and she was amazing and
told me I could actually read books if I
learn the alphabet that's all I needed
to know but yeah mrs. Bevan Thomas was a
tough old [ __ ] who was very very rough
on the class but can I say that is
what's so poignant to me about
questioners it's like I heard I heard
story after story exactly like the one
you told where if somebody had literally
taken ten minutes and sat down with the
child and spoken to them in a reasonable
way and been like this is why we're
asking you to do this the child would
have been like cool I get it Oh in ten
seconds somebody to just like explain
why this isn't just a big waste of my
time and it's like all it would take is
such like instead of you having this
whole kindergarten experience which was
just I mean the simplest response
respectful response to your question
would have solved this it's just to me
so poignant
it's such a waste oh ten yeah ten
seconds I mean literally
Timmy you realize this is what mrs.
Vince convinced ki said to me because I
buy that point I was really digging my
heels because I was so embittered by the
experience with mrs. Bevan mrs. Vince
Keita's very calmly said Tim do you
realize if you learn the alphabet you
can read any book
that you want to read and just like my
head exploded because I was like what
why didn't anybody tell me this and then
I was like raises but yeah I've also is
it like an entrepreneurial type a lot of
people I know who requested it they're
like I don't want to work for anyone
else because I don't I don't trust his
judgment the way I trust my own if I'm
telling myself what to do I know there's
a good reason if other people are like
involved in this it's hard for me like
maybe there's a few trusted people that
I could rely on but I don't want to be
part of a big system where I'm like I
don't know why people are making these
decisions like yeah I want to be yeah I
don't I I can follow decisions as long
as I have the latitude ask questions
such a way that I understand the
rationale but I'm not everyone
responsible to that so that's that's
another thing uh but but to offset the
highly logic oriented framework I've had
to or I haven't had to but I've chosen
to counterbalance that with other things
right so for instance one would be you
mentioned the Cohens is a way to mmm I'm
using my words not yours but get a
reprieve from logic almost right so
there's a quote from I think it's no
Valles I'm not sure if you pronounce it
that way but poetry heals the wounds
inflicted by reason so I've taken time
to try to embrace our forms or
entertainment that is not driven by
logic as a way to medicate myself so
that I'm not purely overweighted in the
reasoning faculty and and I'll give you
another example of that for instance I
interviewed Bosma st. John recently
who's the chief brand officer uber she
was at Apple music and beats and worked
with Spike Lee prior to that a really
incredible woman and and she said when I
was chatting with her that her advice to
her younger self would be do away with
pro and con lists by and large and I
asked her why and she said it's because
usually if you're do if you're creating
a pro and con list you're either trying
to talk to yourself out of bad idea or
talking I'm sorry talk yourself out of a
good idea or talk yourself into a bad
idea wait did I get that yeah out of a
good idea into a bad idea and it made so
much sense to me
and I realized that I've spent a lot of
my I've used my power of questioning in
many cases to try to impose an
analytical framework on things that are
actually best answered with a gut
reaction right it's like if I meet
somebody and I just get the
heebie-jeebies and I really don't if I
really don't like them for an unclear
reason this is this is important right
if it's like mob like they have this
weird tick and it bothers me so what
like it's it's very explicit but if I
get the spider sense going off and I
can't pinpoint why that's a hundred
times out of a hundred something that I
should have paid attention to so I'm for
instance trying to pay more attention to
listening to that as a way to offset
maybe the blunt force use of the
analytical questioning mind for all
situations which I think has been my
default so that's yeah but you know
what's interesting is that both you and
I have talked and I had not put my
finger on this until you until I I heard
what you just said which is like we've
both kind of done things to try to
explicitly offset very like pronounced
parts of our personality like you've
been trying to use this to offset your
questioning side and I've been trying to
use color to bring me into the visual
world which is like hard for me because
I'm so verbal and so I've been trying to
counter that with by making a study of
color so maybe it is kind of this like
you know the opposite of a profound
truth is also true and that you need to
kind of figure out well if you're too
Yin how do you achieve your yang and
maybe both of us are trying to get some
kind of balance and I hadn't thought
about that as kind of a pattern but now
I'm thinking maybe there's a big lesson
here I want to study how do people do it
it's a pretty it's a pretty subtle thing
I don't even realize I was doing it
until you said that
but I wonder how other people like how
you offset that like if you're too
physical how do you tap into spiritual
or if you're to now focus how do you I
don't know like there's a lot of things
people could try to well I think that
in you know we're gonna go squirrely and
all over the place here but from what
I've observed is that if someone has the
luxury of having achieved some degree of
success and it doesn't mean all that
doesn't mean a lot of success but they
have enough of a toehold in professional
success that they don't have to worry
about say where the rent check is coming
from or where the mortgage payment is
coming from and they can put food on the
table at some point they realize not
everybody but many people realize that
the superpower or the strength that
enabled them to get there when used in
excess creates other problems right so
think everything in excess becomes its
opposite to an extent right medicine
becomes right it's like the dose makes
the poison so it's like okay great this
this hyper analytical OCD focus on
whatever has helped you to achieve a
certain degree of financial success and
this done the other thing but then put
into a context of an intimate
relationship you're driving everybody
[ __ ] nuts or whatever right whatever
it might be right and there and then you
realize oh [ __ ] I need to figure out a
practice that can offset this not just
dominant but almost metastasized
tendency to apply this one tool to
everything and so I've certainly seen
that I mean that would be kind of I'll
let you I will I will let you unleash
your own deep dive on this but it's
certainly something that I've seen a lot
of people trying to figure out how can I
take what comes
unnaturally to me that I recognize as
necessary and create a practice of some
type so for me the last thing if you had
told the Tim of 20 years ago that I
would be reading poetry before bed I
mean he would have like vomited on
himself and nonetheless a cure I am and
I find it incredibly relaxing for
whatever reason I and I and part of me
is totally okay with not understanding
the how of it or the why but reading
something like the touted ching which is
not necessarily designated as poetry or
huh Fez or Rumi in the beginning of the
day and at the end of the day to book
end sort of right before I turn on my
hyper analytical mind and then when I
want to turn off my hyper analytical
mind which has historically caused quite
a bit of insomnia dosing myself with
something I never would have used in the
past I find really really helpful
well it's interesting cuz I have this
like I said I have this it's called
moment of happiness newsletter where
every day I send out like a quotation
about happiness or human nature and a
lot of people say oh they like it
because it's I think for you like you're
seeking out poetry but for some people
and you can even go with like the Poetry
Foundation I think like will send you an
email with a poem every day if you want
that but this is like people like to
have that practice of some kind of
transcendent reading first thing in the
morning or right before bed where it's
like it's curated it's something that's
like more beautifully expressed or a
more interesting idea than you're gonna
read in the newspaper or whatever it's
some kind of timeless thing that for
whatever reason is gonna put your brain
in a different place as you start your
day or and your day and I think it's I
think it's a great it's a great thing
I'm a big believer in like things just
like have something to be a small thing
that you can take in and kind of let
fill your mind in a bite-sized piece
rather you know thinking okay I got to
sit down and read ODEs to you know or
wait intimations of immortality and get
this thing done or I'm working my way
through Paradise Lost and like okay
that's okay one page a day just do one
page a day and then that'll be enough to
kind of reset your brain in a positive
way yeah I mean it's and we could we
could keep going but I mean if I've
learned anything about creating let me
let me rephrase that developing habits
that I have somehow failed to develop in
the past
I do less than you think you can I think
is the biggest take away from me it's
like oh you think you can go to the gym
for an hour a day and that's your
resolution to go for five days a week
try like 10 minutes a session three days
a week and that so that your pass/fail
mark is low enough that you don't
abandon ship because you feel like
you've failed especially if you're a
competitive person as I am or with
poetry it's like okay don't choose a
poet that has 10 page poems like go with
someone like frost right frost or Hafez
or Hafez depending on how you want to
say it and the gift right yeah these are
one page or 50 word poems that happen to
very often be hilarious start there and
make it easy and what I found is like if
you want did for me at least it's like
if you want to do things that are really
big this is something new for me
certainly but it it doesn't the path
being hard doesn't indicate that you're
doing something virtuous always right
like in my case at least it's like okay
if I am really loathe to do I'll make
something up but it's like lower leg
ankle prehabilitation so I don't get
injured later doing skiing or whatever
it's boring as [ __ ] it's really pardon
my french but it's like it's really
monotonous and not interesting at all
but if I'm if I tell myself
okay I'm gonna spend this thirty to
sixty Seconds every other day like
before I brush my teeth doing that and
that's it that's enough that's a pass
then I'm setting the hurdle so low that
I'm more inclined to do it and then I
can always do extra credit but if I set
the pass/fail mark too high I'm never
gonna do it in the first place because
or I'll put it off for whatever reason
so in any case ya diatribe I write
complete I write a lot that's like the
whole thing and my book better than
before which is all about habit change
that's like a like a big theme is like
start small start big like how do you
think about that how do you how do you
if you have a haven't like that how
might you think how might you analyze
yourself to know what's going to work
for you
that's that's a perfect example to kind
of have it that it's like it can be in a
way it's not hard in a way it's
extremely hard and like how do you get
yourself to succeed there's like how can
I make this easier how can I make this
year is that so that's the whole
inspiration for better than before is
like what do people do like what what
and it turns out there's 21 strategies
people use and some work better for some
people and some work better for others
and some don't work for some people at
you know some people they don't some
don't work at all and some you can use
it sometimes in your life but not at
other times in your life but it's good
to know the whole panoply of them
because then you can you can say okay
these three so I'm gonna because you
just you said pairing which is doing it
before you brush your teeth yep that's
what I would call the strategy of
pairing scheduling which is putting it
on the schedule like I have an idea of
what I'm gonna do this and safeguards
which is the strategy of thinking how
might I screw up how might I abandoned
this habit I'm gonna think about what is
likely to make me not do it and I'm
gonna figure out a way to solve for that
and you're like if I make this too much
I'm gonna put it offer and I do it I'm
gonna make so I'm knowing taking into
account how I might fail I'm gonna
figure out a way to do it so I don't
fail so again it's like it's it's it's
not that hard when you know what to do
but at the same time you know it can be
very challenging especially if you do it
in a way that's not right for you yeah
for me it's you know make it easy to
pass and I get really expensive to not
do it and it's like if I can be shamed
by let's say a friend of mine who's
gonna bust my chops endlessly if I do it
or somehow try to embarrass me in front
of other friends because we're on a
group text where I committed to a B and
C and it's already on the calendar so I
have this sunk cost of having paid for
lessons and a B and C and someone is
going to show up or be on skype at a
given hour that social accountability
will be very helpful and so on and so
forth so it's BJ Fogg has done some
really cool stuff in this space so Gigi
but Gretchen believer in small stuff he
is yeah the micro steps flossing those
front teeth as he would have somebody to
some people don't like a small there
they want to go bigger but go home
they're not interested in incremental
change they like radical they like big
things and again it's not that there's
one way that's right or one way that's
wrong it's just whatever works for you
if small works for you that's great as
small as boring to you and you're not
gonna stick to it
do something big and bold it's like you
know there's a lot of ways to do this it
just depends there's no magic
one-size-fits-all solution I think it's
just whatever works for us as
individuals yeah for sure well yes it is
not one size fits all but part of the I
suppose excitement if you can look at it
that way is figuring out which which
tools to put in your toolkit over time
well I appreciate the experimental
nature that you bring to bear in your
own life and then in your work that you
share with the world so thank you for
that and thank you so much for the time
today also appreciate it and for
everybody listening you can find links
to everything we have discussed in the
show notes along with the show notes for
every other episode at tim dot blog
forward slash podcast and until next
time as always thank you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun for the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour work week
come that's four hour workweek calm all
spelled out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books man oh man do a lot of listeners
to this podcast and readers of mine love
fresh books to the extent that I into a
meeting with the CEO not very long ago
why are they so popular well they are
the number one cloud accounting software
designed exclusively for self-employed
professionals that's many of you and
used by more than 10 million people you
can send invoices track your time and
get paid very very quickly which suits
the needs of a lot of fool answers a lot
of thoughts my friend owes and beyond
you can take pictures of receipts you
can link your credit card and debit
cards so all the things you buy
automatically appear in your fresh books
in the right category so on and so forth
makes taxes easy makes invoices easy
makes your life easier and also in fact
I recommend a PDF they didn't ask me to
read this part by the way they put the
other PDF a while back called breaking
the time barrier subtitle how to unlock
your true earning potential so you can
search for breaking the time barrier a
lot of people ask me how can I get a
4-hour workweek with a service business
and the story in that ebook it's PDF is
the short answer it's really really good
so I think you should also check that
out so breaking the time error check it
out
but also why not test out fresh books
claim your 30-day unrestricted free
trial at fresh ebooks.com forward slash
tim and enter tim ferriss two hours in
two S's in the how did you hear about us
section that sounds like we're gonna get
very little tracking that's a lot of
work but just go to fresh books comm
forward slash tim and try it out because
it is a very good product and i think
you will find it supervised your life
enjoy this episode is brought to you by
sure sh you are a the company behind
some of my favorite microphones and
headphones in fact this podcast has been
recorded since day one effectively in
all the live interviews with sure
microphones whether
it is the sm58 which looked like stage
mics which bryan callen introduced me to
or the table mounted sm7 bees and most
recently i've been testing one of their
headphones sc8 for six rolls off the
tongue doesn't it
these are now my favorite in-ear
headphones and i always use them when
i'm at coffee shops or when I'm
traveling sure earphones have been
famous for decades now with professional
musicians and their wireless sound
isolating earphones are truly incredible
the reason that I have doubled down on
these earphones specifically is because
when I use these on my laptop as one
example I can keep the volume and say
one out of ten and hear things perfectly
whereas when I use normal earbuds I'm at
easily 7 or 8 out of 10 just to drown
out external noise and I've become very
very concerned with hearing loss I've
seen a lot of my friends losing their
hearing because they're blasting their
ears with normal ear buds on their
phones and laptops and so on so I am
using this as an investment
in my own hearing among other things and
they're very very comfortable the SE 846
which I mentioned the sound isolating
earphones feature a groundbreaking
low-pass filter that delivers extended
high-end clarity and unparalleled
low-end performance so check it out
visit sure comm s sh you re comm forward
slash Tim use the code Tim at checkout
that's capital T I M as a special offer
for listeners of this show you can
receive $100 discount on the SE 846
headphones this offer will only be
available until the end of January 2018
just take a look again that's sure comm
forward slash Tim $400 off
you
you